it looks like we're ending Trump's first
term where it began with members of the
resistance burrowed into government
leaking incomplete information with the
worst possible spin on it all done to
ensnare the president in another major
costly investigation in January 2017 it
was Comey and the deep State in
September 2019 it's Nancy and
whistleblower gate today I'm announcing
the House of Representatives moving
forward with an official impeachment
inquiry the President must be held
accountable no one is above the law well
as of this hour zero Republicans but at
least 179 House Democrats are in favor
of impeachment and why because of
phantom whistleblower reportedly claimed
that the president used the threat of
withdrawing aid to a foreign country
Ukraine to pressure that country into
investigating Jill Biden and his son now
the irony is that the case Trump wanted
investigated involved Biden himself
threatening to withhold a billion dollar
aid package to Ukraine
if a supposedly corrupt prosecutor
wasn't fired he actually bragged about
it well that prosecute prosecutor was
investigating the company barrese ma on
whose board of directors hunter Biden
sat and also that paid him boatloads of
cash oh the fact conveniently glossed
over by most media today the
whistleblower has no first-hand
knowledge of the president's
conversation oh but none of that matters
the actions taken to date by the
president have seriously violated the
Constitution I think what's what is
going on is that the president has
committed several impeachable offenses
he's horrible obviously impeachable
offenses another impeachable offense he
is already I believe the most corrupt
president in American history a
ludicrous yeah the Democrats have
nothing else they know drama Congressman
John Lewis kicked off today's
festivities pouring on the emotion
they come with a heavy heart deeply
concerned about the future of our
democracy and I'm not alone this
incendiary drumbeat all day long had
this effect on the markets the Dow
plunged roughly 200 points before
bottoming out around 1 o'clock well it
recovered after the White House said it
would release a unredacted transcript of
the call with ukrainian President but it
then sunk back by the end of the day
when investors anticipated Pelosi's big
impeachment announcement new calls for
impeachment hitting Wall Street Stocks
slammed after Democratic Congressman
John Lewis called to begin impeachment
proceedings against the president right
now Nancy Pelosi is meeting behind
closed doors with the house Democratic
caucus the speaker will hold a news
conference immediately following that
meeting now the most sickening thing
about the phase and it's a phase that
we're about to enter is that House
Democrats they know impeachment a whole
inquiry is futile the Senate Republican
majority is not going to vote to convict
the president and the country
overwhelmingly doesn't want impeachment
what I think most people do want is a
continuation of what the president has
already delivered America peace and
prosperity the truth is despite all the
dire predictions of a looming Trump
recession that started cut at the end of
last year that now seems highly unlikely
so Democrats are in an unenviable
position going into 2020 that's why they
couldn't even mention the economy at all
at the last debate instead it was all
he's a racist he's a white nationalist
xenophobe and other personal attacks
anything but a serious discussion about
how they would outperform Trump's
economy look it's just a continuation of
the which is the worst which has been
political
we have the strongest economy we've ever
had we have the best unemployment
numbers we've ever had african-american
asian-american Hispanic American the
lowest in history and they're going to
lose the election and they figure this
is a and why would the Democrats risk
destroying the best economy in the world
well the president's right here why
would they risk hurting millions of
entrepreneurs and workers who've seen
wage increases or families who now have
more money in their pockets well it's
not just a president who had a hint
about that earlier today Nancy Pelosi
inadvertently revealed the reason what's
more serious is that he can't win that
is very serious to our country oh yes he
can win Nancy and you and the
overzealous radicals and your caucus
could very well be helping him seal his
second term beyond the grandstanding all
the fulminating today the Democrats
proved once again that they are
incapable of putting the greater good of
the country ahead of their own hatred of
Trump and their thirst to regain power
pushing the nuclear button of
impeachment it's an admission that they
are not confident not in their ideas or
in their candidates can't beat them
impeach them hey why don't they put that
on a bumper sticker and that's the angle